on va parler d'un autre problème la
question des trains et notamment des
trains régionaux géants de Bachir on
vous a suivi dans votre région la région
des Hauts-de-France particulièrement
touchées par la dégradation des
conditions de transport dans les TER
cette année plus de 11000 trains
régionaux ont été annulés à la dernière
minute on regarde ce reportage de Sandra
serreira et émojouré
tous les jours c'est la même incertitude
pour Jérôme Bacher le TER qui doit
l'amener à Gare du Nord pour ensuite
aller au Sénat sera-t-il bien hacké ce
matin là coup de chance le train arrive
à l'heure prévue mais c'est loin d'être
le cas chaque jour cela fait plusieurs
mois que des trains sont supprimés
d'autres raccourcis ou alors en retard
alors ça il y a aucune raison d'être un
plus court un je ne vois pas pourquoi ça
c'est pas un problème de personnel des
rames il y en a et des trains supprimés
autant comme autant et des retards qui
se font sans rien dire on voit les
minutes passées tranquillement on vous
dit plus affichage 2 3 minutes de retard
on passe de du travail arriver à 8h19
8h20 8h21 8h22 donc il vous faut deux
trois trains d'avance pour être sûr
d'arriver à votre travail
il nous a donné rendez-vous à
Orry-la-Ville dans l'Oise depuis
quelques semaines il part plutôt car le
train de 8h35 a été supprimé sans être
remplacé
usager du TER au quotidien il entend
bien dénoncer la dégradation des
conditions de transport depuis le début
de l'année 11000 TER ont été supprimés
dans les hauts de France soit une hausse
de 134% en 3 ans des suppressions liées
à des difficultés de recrutement il
manque une soixantaine de conducteurs
dans la région
de chauffeurs c'est absolument
impossible à entendre c'est vraiment une
gestion à la petite semaine alors c'est
très compliqué j'entends c'est très
compliqué là
à la fin c'est 1130 supprimer chapeau
donc dans la région donc c'est pas que
60 chauffeurs qui font une centrale je
crois autre problème l'exploitation des
TER qui coûte de plus en plus cher aux
régions notamment à cause de la flambée
des prix de l'É
vice-président de la Région
Hauts-de-France en charge des transports
Franck dersin se dit inquiet pour
l'avenir des lignes régionales
un million 450 000 euros par jour c'est
ce que l'on met sur le TER 535 millions
d'euros donc on met beaucoup d'argent et
on n'a pas le résultat c'est vous voulez
face à cet argent investi les régions
toutes les régions aujourd'hui sont en
train d'investir des dizaines de
millions d'euros des centaines de
millions d'euros et on le fait sur une
infrastructure qui nous appartient pas
c'est à dire qu'on investit à la place
de SNCF réseau à la place de l'État et
ça c'est insupportable et quand on
regarde le budget qui a été mis voté
récemment avec le rejet d'ailleurs d'une
rallonge de 3 milliards d'euros qui
avait été demandés par toutes les
oppositions sur un 49-3 et bien on
s'aperçoit que l'État ne met pas assez
les Allemands ont mis des milliards 84
milliards les Italiens plus de 70
milliards les Autrichiens l'ont fait les
Hollandais l'ont fait nous on met 3 mill
et demi d'euros par an sur le réseau
alors qu'il faudrait un plan de 10
milliards d'euros par an pendant 10 ans
la SNCF a promis davantage de TER sur
les lignes des Hauts de France mais le
service reste dégradé dans l'attente la
région a suspendu au moins partiellement
ces paiements à la SNCF alors il y a
beaucoup d'enseignements à attirer de ce
reportage d'abord j'ai embachère
puisqu'on vous a vu est-ce que c'est une
situation qui dure depuis longtemps
est-ce que c'est une situation qui
s'aggrave
les chiffres sont très parlants plus 134
% de train supprimer en trois ans dans
la situation s'aggrave juste si je
n'avais pas dormi à Paris ce qu'on a
fini la loi de finance rectificative
hier soir un peu tard je ne serai pas
sur votre plateau ce matin je ne serai
pas sur votre plateau ce matin parce que
à Goussainville caténaire a été arraché
et tout ce qu'on appelle le barreau y
Picard c'est-à-dire tout ce qui va
jusque Creil et puis après ça sépare
d'un côté Amiens d'un côté Saint-Quentin
et bien cela aujourd'hui dysfonctionne
complètement voilà
en fait cette nuit avec beaucoup de
temps des arbres et que du coup
je le dis faire un débat d'orientation
budgétaire parce que la caténaire s'est
arraché dans le train où j'étais donc en
milieu d'après-midi il y avait rien il
faisait beau c'était magnifique donc
j'allais je prends le train de 13h34 et
je suis arrivé à Paris Nord à 18h il
faut 18 minutes de trajet donc j'ai été
transborder de train etc comme tout le
monde mais oui ça arrive mais quel que
soit votre heure donc ça n'arrête pas
parce qu'il n'y a pas eu d'entretien
pendant des années et aujourd'hui il
faut faire un rattrapage mais ça sert à
rien de dire qu'on va mettre 30
milliards d'un coup on sait pas les
dépenser hier nos amis Hervé Moret et
Stéphane sotarel les spécialiste de la
SNCF à la commission des finances nous
expliquer qu'il y a des sommes qui ne
sont pas utilisées elles ne sont pas
utilisées parce que ils sont incapables
aujourd'hui de de faire évidemment sur
ces questions Camille c'est une
dégradation du réseau quotidien pour les
gens du réseau ordinaire du un
sous-investissement chronique depuis des
années oui un sous-investissement depuis
des années c'est effectivement connu on
a mis beaucoup d'argent sur les TGV
c'était la priorité pendant des années
l'argent que vous mettez un endroit vous
ne le mettez pas ailleurs et on s'est
réveillé à un moment ça se rend compte
finalement est-ce qu'on n'a pas laissé
de côté une grande partie du réseau donc
ça quand vous n'investissez pas
forcément au bout d'un moment ça se
dégrade et ça entraîne des problèmes des
caténaires arrachés des talus qui
s'effondre ou même si les trains ne sont
pas coupés la vitesse est ralentie par
sécurité aussi et ça ça peut rallonger
les temps de parcours ça veut dire que
pour les usagers parce que le
gouvernement mise aussi beaucoup sur les
trains parce que c'est plus écologique
comme moyen de transport ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui vous dites on ne peut pas
miser sur le train comme moyen de
transport du quotidien vous n'êtes pas
sûr d'arriver à l'heure moi j'ai raté
plusieurs rendez-vous y compris des
rendez-vous médicaux vous savez où il
faut six mois parfois et vous les ratez
tout simplement premier train supprimé
deuxième train en retard bon ben voilà
vous avez c'est fini vous avez pris une
heure et demie dans la vue et c'est la
responsabilité de qui tout ça pour vous
c'est la SNCF le contrat il est clair et
les contrats il y a un contrat il est
signé alors ils sont parfois durs les
contrats mais ils sont signés et bien
des sommes d'argent et à la fin il n'y a
pas le service qui va avec il y a toute
chose que j'en oublie parce qu'on parle
forcément je suis sensible
nationale et chemin de fer français ceci
dit national les chevalières français
ils ne répondent plus le monsieur
farando je l'aime beaucoup je connais
peu mais il répond plus au parlementaire
il fait répondre les autres et aux
anciens ministres il répond plus voilà
il est déjà bah non je peux rien faire
mais si les patrons d'une société
nationale il y a des SNCF est peut-être
organisée en région mais qu'on est
patron d'une société nationale et bien
on répond au contrat signé et donc on
déplace les personnels pour pouvoir
remplir le contrat signé c'est la norme
justement on va écouter la réponse de la
SNCF pas de Jean-Pierre farando mais du
patron du directeur TER délégué chez
SNCF voyageur il s'appelle jean-humé
Mougenot il était avec Sandra cerkara
nous avons certainement formé plus de
800 conducteurs cette année et puis nous
avons aussi
lancé une solidarité entre entre
région ce qui nous permet d'ailleurs de
rajouter depuis lundi donc depuis le
depuis lundi 14 novembre c'est ce qui
nous permet de rajouter des trains nous
avons supprimé 136 trains pour pour
sur la base du plan de transport
habituel à partir du 24 octobre et donc
nous en rajoutons en 17 depuis le 14
novembre et et les résultats sont plutôt
bons nous ciblons d'ailleurs des trains
qui sont sensibles et trains qui sont
importants pour les voyageurs et la
deuxième étape que nous prévoyons de se
redressement c'est celle du du 12 du 12
décembre avec 21 trains supplémentaires
il nous manquera donc à part aux 12
décembre il nous manquera plus qu'une
centrale centaine de trains sur les sur
les 1250 qui circulent tous les jours
tous les jours en haut de France voilà
au niveau national
devrait avoir honte c'est une véritable
onde aux osé dire ça et puis lundi il y
a des trains de plus effectivement il
dit le nombre de traces c'est grotesque
sans trains mais 136 trains par jour
parce que donc à la fin du mois vous
multipliez par 30 moi je suis assez
basique comme garçon on est à des
chiffres qui sont encore bien supérieurs
aux 1101 qui manquent chaque mois on est
encore triplé c'est ça qu'on est en
train de nous dire on triple en ce
moment le nombre de trains supprimés
triplé alors il y a un problème à la
SNCF c'est le manque de conducteurs
est-ce que vous l'entendez ça à ce
problème oui mais à quoi il nous dit on
a déplacé des conducteurs donc du coup
on a dit train de plus par jour vous
rendez compte du ridicule de ce qui
vient de nous raconter là non mais ça va
pas Camille
quelqu'un qui vous répond ça c'est
absolument scandaleux c'est absolument
scandaleux
[Musique]
j'aimerais bien que il y avait lundi ou
novembre dernier une manifestation ou ce
matin je sais plus une manifestation à
Lille et une manifestation qui va avoir
lieu sur Creil pour dire il y en a marre
sur notamment la question du manque de
conduire puisque
c'est une des raisons
de en réalité la SNCF est confronté au
même problème que beaucoup d'entreprises
la RATP a la même chose en Île-de-France
et on a les mêmes problèmes à Paris mais
c'est dans plein de secteurs
pendant le covid en fait il y a un
certain nombre de gens qui n'ont pas
travaillé parce qu'on a arrêté beaucoup
l'économie qui ont réfléchi qui ont un
peu changé de vie qui sont pas revenus à
ces métiers là et ensuite ça c'est un
peu aggravé puisque c'est des métiers
qui en fait sont pas très attractifs il
y a souvent le mythe du cheminot mais en
réalité vous vous êtes en horaire coupé
vous travaillez le week-end la nuit les
jours fériés pas forcément très bien
payés donc en fait on n'arrive plus à
recruter et en fait on se retrouve avec
la même chose dans la restauration sauf
que forcément quand vous manquez de
serveur dans un restaurant ça fait pas
le même effet que quand vous manquez de
chauffeur à la SNCF vous les entendez
ces arguments à jouer en Bachir tout
n'est pas la faute de la SNCF alors vous
savez que par ailleurs je siège donc
sénateur c'est une illustration la
Caisse des dépôts qui est l'un des
propriétaires de Transdev
donc c'est un sujet que nous connaissons
même ici résolu les contrats ils sont
respectés les contrats ils sont
respectés chez Transdev voilà c'est tout
donc il y a des entreprises qui savent
se mobiliser qui savent résoudre des
problèmes avant la rentrée scolaire on
avait un sujet de chauffeur dans les
hauts de France oui le président
Bertrand il s'est mobilisé il s'est
mobilisé avec les transporteurs on a
trouvé les solutions la SNCF elle trouve
pas les solutions on discute avec l'État
et avec le gouvernement Audrey oui le
gouvernement qui a été interpellé lors
des questions au Gouvernement c'était
une question de Madame Rossignol et le
ministre délégué au transport a fait des
annonces écoutées
il y a une pénurie de conducteur et donc
j'ai demandé qu'il y a un plan tout à
fait exceptionnel pour les hauts de
France qui soit mis en place inédit avec
des recrutements qui sont le plus
accélérés possible pour qu'on résolve
ces difficultés de pénurie et donc de
galère du quotidien pour beaucoup de
gens en Île-de-France on a une situation
qui est difficile aussi il y a un plan
qui a été mis en place d'ores et déjà
par la RATP ça prend un peu de temps
pour recruter aussi massivement on
travaille avec la région qui a
l'organisation la responsabilité de
l'organisation des transports pour que
cela s'améliore le plus vite possible il
faut mettre la pression sur tout le
monde pour qu'on y arrive
Talis pour aller à Bruxelles il est on
connaît pas bien les transports du
quotidien ça c'est sûr et les prend pas
beaucoup je peux le comprendre
il a pris donc le TGV mais je vous
assure la ligne TGV fonctionne à peu
près correctement donc il y a
effectivement des gens qui commutent par
le TGV faut pas mépriser du tout le TGV
je méprise pas mais c'est pas
l'essentiel les voyageurs en haut de
France et c'est pas tout forcément les
mêmes j'ai dit les mêmes niveaux de
revenus faut penser aussi comme visage
impérat à la frange d'en bas ça veut
dire qu'il y a un risque de fracture
territoriale de fracture sociale Camille
selos sur cette question des difficultés
des transports du quotidien
les transports c'est toujours un risque
de crise sociale les dernières années le
souvent venu de ces domaines là donc
plus souvent ça vient de la route des
carburants les gilets jaunes etc est-ce
que la prochaine fois ça viendra de je
vous avez dû je pense lire bon on est
beaucoup à l'avoir lu le reportage de
lubrère dans le monde qui était un long
reportage dans la galère justement des
dans les hauts de France c'est en plus
la France qui travaille tôt enfin pour
l'instant bon c'est pas des gens qui se
sont plus mobilisés que ça mais il y a
une lassitude forcément après la
responsabilité elle est quand même
plutôt partagée moi je critiquerai pas
uniquement la SNCF c'est un jeu à trois
entre l'État les régions la SNCF
[Musique]
a besoin de deux à quatre ans pour faire
un projet de des projets de travaux ces
deux ans c'est au moins deux ans à
l'avance si vous devez couper un moment
un bout de ligne de chemin de fer donc
c'est un vrai processus très très long
la SNCF très bien organisé sur de ce
point de vue là et alors du point de vue
des ressources humaines c'est vraiment
la cata la multiplicité des entités
aussi ne faciles pas la mutation entre
les agents et donc vous avez un souci
majeur de gestion des ressources
humaines notamment de la SNCF on va
sortir un peu de votre région c'est un
problème qui ne concerne pas que les
haut c'est le problème dans les
transports du quotidien Andrea ça
concerne beaucoup de régions oui et une
carte permet de s'en rendre compte on va
vous la montrer elle a été réalisée par
des journalistes du site reporters et on
y découvre un hexagone essentiellement
jaune et orange et bien c'est là où ça
ne va pas du tout côté TER en orange ce
sont les lignes qui ont un besoin urgent
de travaux et en jaune les lignes qui
sont fortement dégradées la
quasi-totalité de la France en fait pour
continuer sur le constat en Rhône-Alpes
401 TER sont supprimés chaque jour du
côté du réseau francilien c'est 12 RER
qui sont annulés quotidiennement sur la
ligne C 19 sur la ligne D et vous l'avez
dit quand les trains circulent souvent
ils sont ralentis car le système est
vieillissant et il faut donc ralentir
les trains pour assurer la sécurité des
passagers pour terminer une information
qui est peut-être anecdotique mais ça
vous donne une idée de la situation sur
le réseau il y a encore des postes de
guidage de train qui date des années 30
c'est assez surprenant et quand on voit
cette carte c'est même assez inquiétant
oui alors moi je suis pas surprise c'est
un vieux sujet en réalité on avait
d'ailleurs été recrutée le PDG des
chemins de fer belges pour répondre à
cette question puisqu'en Belgique vous
parlez des aiguillages ils avaient
réussi à moderniser tout ça automatiser
on l'avait recréé pour ça il est arrivé
avec son franc-parler il a dit vous
m'avez recruté pour ça je vous demande
des moyens en face je ne les ai pas bras
de fer de plusieurs mois et puis
finalement comment ça s'est fini
septembre il est limogé parce que il a
crié un peu trop fort donc c'est la
contradiction aussi c'est pour ça que je
me dis la SNCF n'est pas que responsable
c'est la contradiction de l'État qui
pousse sur le ferroviaire et qui en même
temps ne met pas les moyens qui qu'il
faudrait et là pour le coup je me suis
pas une position personnelle c'est
vraiment partager collectivement qui est
un constat que ce soit dans la majorité
l'opposition tous les gens du secteur
sont d'accord sur le fait qu'il faut
mettre plus d'argent dans le réseau et
Jean-Pierre Ferrando aussi et
l'ouverture à tous les mêmes chiffres
il se trouve qu'il y a eu un rapport
fait par mes amis sotarelles et Moret au
mois de mars qui explique qu'il manque
un milliard par an
qui peut être dépensé pour la
modernisation des vignes c'est à dire
les vieux
etc on pourrait mettre des postes
électriques ça existe l'électricité
quand même au 21e siècle et un milliard
pour ce qu'on appelle la régénération
c'est à dire les petites lignes
justement qui ont besoin d'entretien il
faut 2 milliards par an de plus c'est la
somme qui sait être dépensée si vous
dites remets 3 à 4,5 on peut sortir des
chiffres on dit 10 milliards par an ce
que dit Franck Bersin il a il a raison
mais on ne sait pas les dépenser on aura
pas les entreprises on n'a pas les
ingénieurs etc donc ça sert à rien de
mettre de l'argent qui ne sera pas
dépensé et ce sont des chiffres partagés
politiques
techniquement et par la SNCF il manque
de milliards par an ouais est-ce que
j'ai aussi Franck bersen dans le
reportage de Sandra c'est que l'État met
beaucoup moins que ses voisins européens
il a raison là-dessus oui oui ça il y a
les l'Italie et l'Allemagne notamment
ont annoncé des grands plans c'est ce
que demande Jean-Pierre farandoux aussi
avec un plan de plusieurs milliards je
crois que c'est 100 milliards sur 15 ans
les présidents de région ont fait une
tribune commune aussi et pour appeler un
New Deal donc je pense que oui mais en
fait c'est censé être en cours de
discussion si vous voulez c'est
classique en politique chacun demande et
puis vous avez Matignon ou l'Élysée qui
doit avoir arbitré entre des demandes de
milliards pour l'hôpital pour le
ferroviaire enfin Camille vous le
rappeler effectivement les présidents de
région qui sont unanimes sur ce sujet
Audrey oui quinze président de région
qui ont donc réclamé un New Deal
ferroviaire vous en avez parlé avec un
budget de 10 milliards d'euros par an
pendant 10 ans pour anticiper remettre à
niveau le réseau ferroviaire pour
l'instant ils ont pas de réponse du
gouvernement mais le gouvernement qui a
promis qu'il allait investir plus et
alors là les sénateurs s'inquiètent
parce qu'ils ont regardé le budget 2023
et en fait il pas grand chose sur la
régénération des lignes dans ce budget
c'est votre avis monsieur
bons spécialistes qui nous le disent ça
manque d'argent donc on est vraiment
très embêté on est à la limite de
papoter ce budget je vais juste vous
donner un petit exemple parce que vous
avez tout à fait raison lorsque vous
dites que l'État arbitre entre ces
différentes priorités mais je vous donne
juste deux chiffres sur le budget le les
investissements dans le budget de la
France ça va être 27 milliards en 2023
27 milliards il y a 430 milliards de
budget
vous êtes à 5%
ça ne va pas ce pays s'appauvri ces
infrastructures s'appauvrissent nous
sommes en train de nous dire mon disait
mais comment vous l'expliquez
politiquement parce que il y avait Jean
Castex qui étaient à Matignon qui est
plutôt sensible sur la question des
transports la preuve maintenant il a
RATP il y a Élisabeth borde alors
qu'elle vient de la RATP comment vous
expliquer
pas à cette question
il y a un sujet avec la région
Île-de-France sur la RATP qui est majeur
prenez la ligne 4 là pour venir au Sénat
moi je regarde les Denis que je prends
la RER B la ligne 4 c'est devenu
infernal la ligne 4 qui qui maintenant
quasiment automatique donc ça ne va pas
question politique
on a investi pas personne veut être
d’argent pour investir parce que quand
vous êtes en co-responsabilité vous
n'avez jamais le bénéfice politique
alors du coup vous laissez la patate
chaude à l'autre ça c'est une mauvaise
façon de faire moi je crois la
responsabilité totale plus qu'à la
responsabilité partielle où chacun se
renvoie la balle vous avez une
explication je partage un peu c'est en
plus c'est pas sexy d'investir dans le
réseau ça se voit pas vous changez des
postes de Liège vous coupez jamais de
ruban c'est bien plus rentable
politiquement d'aller inaugurer une
ligne TGV et Jean Castex d'ailleurs
quand il était là il avait beau dire que
il était très favorable votre train ce
qu'il a surtout fait c'est qu'il a
relancé trois lignes de TGV et ça
beaucoup lui ont dit par contre c'est
bien on comprend les Toulousains
d'ailleurs sont ravis Carole del gap
pousse beaucoup pour ça mais après il y
a aussi le réseau et après il y a
l'affrontement classique avec Bercy qui
n'est pas forcément connu pour être prêt
à investir et puis on est dans un
contexte très compliqué on dépense des
milliards partout on a la comparaison
classique c'est il faut x milliards pour
le ferroviaire mais on a on vient de
dépenser 7,5 milliards pour soutenir les
prix à la pompe et qui était pas du tout
un investissement qui était très
immédiat et en même temps est-ce que
c'était un choix mais en même temps
est-ce qu'on était prêt à laisser les
Français faire le plein à plus de 2
euros du litre voilà c'est des choix
politiques
selon chaque famille politique
le vrai sujet c'est qu'effectivement on
est drogué à la dépense publique et la
quelque chose de fonctionnement et donc
l'investissement ça se dégrade
tranquillement chaque année
négligemment au rythme des
amortissements quand on est chef
d'entreprise on sait qu'il faut amortir
ces comptes et ses investissements et
bien là ça s'amortit mais on ne met pas
l'argent derrière pour réinvestir c'est
le problème de l'État qui a un peu un
peu mieux il faut mieux entretenir au
fur et à mesure et sur les régions ce
qu'on entendait monsieur dersin dans le
reportage dire on investit sur une
infrastructure qui ne nous appartient
pas en investit à la place de la SNCF
réseau à la place de l'État là aussi là
il a raison Camille céleste c'est toute
une architecture qui est à revoir en
fait alors on vient de la revoir avec la
réforme de 2018 la SNCF donc je pense
que c'est pas le moment de remettre
l'ouvrage sur le métier je pense que
personne a très envie de ça au contraire
faut un peu que ça se stabilise donc
c'est effectivement SNCF réseau qui gère
le réseau c'est payé par l'état de plus
en plus par les régions aussi avec les
contrats de plans et ta région avec des
accords qui sont en cours de discussion
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça aussi que le
moment est un peu sensible c'est qu'on
commence à discuter à discuter des
volets transports de c'est ce qu'on
appelle les CP dans le jargon qui
doivent aboutir d'ici septembre d'ici la
fin du premier semestre pardon 2023 et
chacun essaye de faire comprendre que
ben non c'est pas à moi de payer c'est
de la négo hein
les régions parce que du coup il y a
aussi une augmentation des prix de
l'énergie c'est aussi qui rentre en
compte évidemment alors il y a des
régions qui préfèrent mettre moins de 30
autres qui préfèrent augmenter les
tarifs en tout cas qui n'ont pas le
choix que d'augmenter le tarif des
utilisateurs est-ce que du coup ça fait
porter une responsabilité sur les
présidents de région pour vous bien sûr
mais bon c'est la loi donc il y a une
responsabilité si vous voulez pas
assumer de responsabilité vous faites
pas président de région il faut mieux
éviter c'est bien que c'est pas
forcément à la mode mais non non faut
prendre ses responsabilités on fait des
choix on fait des arbitrages
qui est décentralisée donc chaque région
arbitre comme elle le veut et comme elle
le peut surtout en ce moment parce que
sur toutes les difficultés qu'on a
évoqué effectivement se rajoute cette
couche de la crise énergétique qui coûte
très très cher pour l'avenir dans une
régionale pour conclure selon vous ça
dépend de l'arbitrage qui va suivre sur
les finances délit national monsieur
farando nous a dit là le problème qu'on
a sur les lignes régionales dans quatre
ans nous l'aurons sur les lignes
nationales c'est nous passons par la
vitesse supérieure il nous l'a dit
pour l'avenir du ferroviaire tout court
exactement la décision elle se prend
maintenant soit on y va on met l'argent
et ça peut bien se passer soit on ne le
met pas et dans ce cas là oui on va au
devant de grands problèmes et ce sera le
mot de la fin pas très réjouissant mais
ce sera le mot de la fin merci beaucoup
de nous avoir éclairé sur ce débat on va
passer à la revue de presse on va parler
Picard Jérôme Bacher attention c'est
excellent
[Musique]